on ne fait pas une perquisition comme ça
chez un journaliste il faut que ce soit
fondée et on prend pas les données d'un
journaliste sans disque dur etc
mais je ne peux pas le retravailler
parle très bien ce n'est pas au dessus
des lois ont compris ce qu'est un
meeting avant la prochaine fois non mais
attendez je mange le système c'est quoi
je viens où chaque fois que je vous
m'invitez pour que vous durant minutes
que j'allais si hier nous abîmer pas ce
qu'a fait des années que le sketch
existe non mais vous nous aimez bien
chaque fois tu sais mais a dénoncé un
débat c'est normal qu'à voir autre truc
le sketch et ceci n'est que je parle je
n'étais pas général au bout de deux
trois 3 mo ou trois phrases yaqub
aprilia venezuela bon vous le vouliez ou
encore dit oui à la profession de
journaliste elle doit être protégée
comme celle d'avocat on perquisitionne
pas le cabinet d'avocats comme ça et de
la même façon un local politique où il
ya le fichier le nom et les adresses de
tous nos adhérents c'est sensible et je
veux être certain si cette perquisition
a lieu qu'elle est fondée d'accord
j'aimerais savoir qui a donné l'ordre et
pour un sujet aussi sensible et je
proposerai que ce sera plutôt un juge
d'instruction et voire même plusieurs
juges d'instruction pour qu une
collégialité de la décision là dans
cette affaire c'est pas le cas d'accor
est bon alors ça vous questionne pas ça
si ça me fait juste enlevé manchots
mélenchon accablé marine le pen et
fillon pour les mêmes raisons il se
réjouissait dans dix ans les autres
bonne mine
ils ont bonne mine de s'opposer à la
justice examine voquer et n'allez pas
s'étonner que c'est justement est ce
qu'une partie de françois fillon tu peux
main oui mais justement ce que pascal
mesut özil ya un doc gynéco qui se
recoiffe et vous le gêner alors ils
feront quoi donc voila merci à l'excès
parce que il ya un truc est vrai pour le
coup lorsque vous venez de dire la
province moi je reconnais je reconnais
mais que les choses soient qu' avec le
recul la manière dont a été traité
françois fillon par l'élection
présidentielle moi je questionne ça et
que ce soit car bien sûr les magistrats
doivent pouvoir travailler la justice
doit faire son travail
m'enfin on est un candidat qui s'est
fait foudroyer pendant la campagne
présidentielle et on est 18 mois après
la campagne présidentielle
aucune de décembre justice mais
aujourd'hui mais j'ai fini aujourd'hui
même la bête a été bouclée mais auquel
est l'un des employeurs de vannes fillon
a reconnu l emploi fictif haut que
j'aurais aujourd'hui ont des juges mais
devant ces avancées la sarre a pas
décision de justice qui a été rendue
aujourd'hui
non non son employeur de mener l enquête
préliminaire a été menée avec un
jugement la forme de l'anc est donc vous
confirmez
je m'attendais arrêté de me traiter de
menteur parce que je viens de dire la
vérité j'ai dit que vous préfériez de
temps j'entendais contre vichy de 18
mois après l'élection présidentielle
aucune décision de justice est rendue
moi effectivement aujourd'hui je n'ai vu
tout à l'heure une que effectivement
c'est bouclé bon ce que je veux dire
c'est que mine de rien j'invite chacun à
réfléchir sur le fait que la justice
peut percuter notre vie politique parce
que cette élection présidentielle ça
devait pas être mariée et elle a gagné
et il ya eu quand même une situation où
un candidat serge dufour en est un autre
qui domine encore le comtat mais je sais
qu'il va comprendre foire aux vins
d'alsace ce que je dis pas par contre
c'est qu'il ya eu peut-être mes habits
de monsieur macron effectivement
vis-à-vis de certains dossiers qui
auraient pu amener à skis édition de
justice parlant d'un voyage qu'il a fait
à l'étranger et un meeting qu'il a fait
notamment aux états unis par exemple le
fait qu y compris pour revenir faire un
peu parler de défendre ses comptes de
campagne
de la même façon la même commission
nationale des comptes de campagne
interroge sur des choses qui ne sont pas
normales dans les comptes de campagne
des manuels macron tout ça aurait pu
amener à ce que et d'ailleurs même je
sais pas si tout ce qui n'aura dit
suivent celui qui nous a mis en cause à
la commission nationale des comptes de
campagne sa mère et qui s'appelle
monsieur de chalvron il dit là où
mélenchon a raison c'est que tous les
candidats ou du moins les grands
candidats
aussi il ya des problèmes taille de
leurs comptes de campagne donc ce que j
sais pour quelle raison nous on se mange
une perquisition dans des dimensions
jamais vu
mais alexis cléricaux n'explique pas le
comportement adéquat je voudrais redire
en design et rémy je voudrais rebondir
bien deux choses d'abord il rebondit un
alexis ce qui est dommage c'est que le
débat que tu poses est intéressant il
faut le mener dans une démocratie d'un
jeune république mais on peut par une
indignation à deux vitesses - géométrie
variable il l'aurait fallu
pour être crédible
les propos que tu tiens sur la sphère
fillon qui les tiennent au moment de la
présidentielle
or là on a entendu personne c'est
deuxièmement accablé oui presque il
était accablé il voulait créer une image
aussi à s'attaquer à la police était
allé vers les sages les deux éléments
vous auriez pu poser le débat en des
termes clairs tranquille serein pourquoi
vous êtes excité quand on s'excite sur
une paire clément qui était
perquisitionné chez moi je les ai
laissés perquisitionné que tu n'as rien
à te reprocher quand tu es serais tu les
laisses rentrée allez-y faites votre
travail
mahut sont même restés chez lui la merci
merci mais si tu montre la fébrilité et
tu obligé un moment nos mains de tenir
mais s'ils veulent pas être
perquisitionné ce qu'ils ont peut-être
des choses à se reprocher ces gens là je
rappelle tout le monde a été
perquisitionnée que ça s'est passé que
les idées des entretiens mais la
personne perquisitionnée à 7h du matin
et s'est même à 6 heures la perquisition
mais ils font pas ils font pas tout un
foin est il respecté les lois de la
république mais un seul vrai candidat
présidentiel qui explique qu'il ait la
république la république c'est nous
c'est pas lui c'est nous la république